hi everyone today we're going to talk
about cross functional communication
we're going to talk about the benefits
it has some of the challenges that it
brings and some techniques that will
allow you to make it more effective
so I don't know about you guys but
oftentimes I'd tend to oversimplify the
why some company succeeds let me give
you some examples for example Google you
know I think they have a great product
and they're great engineers the
companies FedEx greater operations
nobody beats them at operations Apple
the best product design and user
interface that is out there
Zappos who hasn't order tapestries
online and said this is the best
customer experience I've ever had or
even optically and if you remember the
OxiClean guy what a great salesman right
but a reality all these companies not
only succeed because they're great and
doing one thing but because they have
the ability to grow it to work
successfully across different functional
areas so let me walk you through some of
the things that make us believe that
working across functional teams is great
first diversity cross-functional teams
bring together people with a variety of
background experiences skills together
second innovation it is proven that
cross-functional teams have the ability
to solve more complex problems and cross
function and that cross-functional teams
has an enhanced capacity for a creative
solutions third productivity
cross-functional teams have better
communication across functional areas
and they a member of a cross-functional
team is I don't know for example
engineers working with someone for
marketing it's likely that they will
develop skills or learn skills from the
other people they would otherwise not
have developed finally company I like it
cross-functional teams allowed to
develop a shared vision and a aligned
set of goals by understanding the other
areas needs and challenges so for all
these reasons we leave that
cross-functional teams are great way to
go whoa hold on afraid of not only our
cross-functional team is not always the
best thing I'd say from many of our
experiences cross-functional teams fail
they fail in four different ways
familiarity aims isolation and language
so let me tell you about these four
things who is this man that's right
Metta World Peace very very very good um
he is a power forward now for those of
you who know basketball some of you even
know who Metta World Peace is but even
if you don't simply me telling you that
he's a power forward gives you some idea
of what kind of play style he has what
his role is on a team maybe even what
height and weight he is but for those of
us who don't know basketball if I told
you that he was a power forward that
would be literally meaningless to you
think how much more true that is in
business where the jargon we use is
laced with and backed by years of
understanding of our field in a
cross-functional team that experience
isn't there and so familiarity works
against us what about Ames we might
think that it's easy for us to decide on
a single goal but on a cross function
team it's pretty difficult a
cross-functional team might come into a
meeting ready to decide what to do about
a failing product and half of the team
might come in with redesigns of the
product and the other half of the team
might come in with ideas on how to scrap
the product what about a more subtle
sort of difference what if you came in
to a meeting where you were supposed to
think about a new idea and the
data-driven side of the team came in
with with extensive research and the
creative side of the team came in with
open minds ready to brainstorm neither
of those is wrong but it leads to the
sort of miscommunication that causes
cross-functional teams to falter and
fail
what about isolation if you go into a
cross-functional team why should you as
an engineer learn what sales is doing
why should you as a finance person learn
what engineering is doing it doesn't
make sense but without that
understanding it's impossible for you to
get anything done you simply relegate
and you don't think about their problems
and then when they complain to you about
their problems you say yeah you should
solve that right you're the expert and
it's that sort of misunderstanding
between the members of a
cross-functional team that unwillingness
to think about what is she doing here
what is she contributing that I need to
learn from that causes those
cross-functional teams not to work and
finally there's language and I wanted to
talk about word dating
at the beginning of the century the word
dating probably meant that you are
seeing a different person every night of
the week these days it might mean that
you're in a committed relationship
depending on geography and depending on
your personal preferences for scientists
it means you're trying to find the age
of a fossil and this is this is a common
word this is a word that we use all the
time think how many more meanings are
inherent in a word that's used in
business how many misinterpretations of
a simple phrase there can be so for
these four reasons for familiarity for
aims for isolation for language
cross-functional teams are doomed to
fail oh wait a minute I'm saying I
wouldn't go that far
cross-functional teams can actually be
successful that is of course if you
understand and use the fundamental basic
building blocks of excellence the first
one make sure you tell a compelling
story if you're going to get all the
people from sales and marketing and
finance into one room make sure they
have a clear and motivating mission if
I'm working at Google and I tell you
we're going to work on a new recording
device maybe that's not so exciting if I
tell you it's Google glass and it's the
next innovation and recording and
Experion it's going to change the way
people experience the world that is a
compelling story and that's a reason
that prospection 'el teams need to work
together secondly communicate simply and
clearly there's no need for jargon you
don't have to prove you're an expert in
this room you don't have to use
technical language that will confuse
people consultants are great at this if
I tell you I'm a consultant and I say I
need that deck on SWAT by Co B you might
know what that means you might not you
might not understand that I want a
PowerPoint presentation on the strengths
and weaknesses of an organization by the
close of business that will really
confuse things communicate clearly be
simple the third building block meet
frequently to share ideas many times
people think oh cross-functional teams
that's where I once a month meeting that
I'd read shalva that's for the quarterly
meeting I'll just focus on it when it
gets here
the cross-functional teams are actually
far more effective if they meet more
frequently
and less formally a great example of a
company that does this is Facebook the
company lunches aren't just a waste of
money our time it's an informal way to
give people from different sectors
together so I can understand what people
in different parts of the organization
are doing and we can work to better work
together better when it comes time
finally be willing to put yourself in
other people's shoes
this means active and open listening you
have to be willing to engage with people
from other departments and understand
what their motivations and challenges
are so if we're all working at schwim on
the same bicycle product sales might
want it to be bluer finance might want
it to be cheaper the engineers they
might want it to be safer without active
and open listening you'll never know
that be sure to put yourself in other
people's shoes so now that we've told
you some of the ways cross-functional
teams can benefit organizations what's
in it for you
why is it in your worth while to make
sure you become a better person on
cross-functional teams the answer is you
can become a standout leader people that
can master this skill are better able to
perform well in their organizations it
helps you promote cooperation across
departments and it also gives you the
ability to enhance the diversity and
scope of your network you can build
credibility and influence not just in
whatever cone or section you're in but
across the company more importantly it
helps you understand the bigger picture
what is our overall company mission the
more you know about the company the more
successful successful you can be
finally and most importantly you create
a reputation every time you're in those
meetings with the sales and the finance
and the marketing people you're building
a reputation that will far outlast
whatever project it is you're working on
these are five huge reasons why we think
you should avoid fail learn how to work
on cross-functional teams and learn how
to be successful on them we think this
could make you a better leader not just
on individual projects but in your
company and your career overall so we
think with that maybe you might want to
go out and try some of these strategies
but we're sure you have some questions
which we're happy to answer
you